today we had a very long discussion on
migration leaders agreed that 40,000
persons in need will be relocated from
Greece and Italy to other states over
the next two years and another 20,000
will be resettled so that is a total of
60,000 persons in need of protection as
ever it's been a with these things been
a long night we've discussed some very
important subjects but above all I'm
delighted that the process of British
reform and renegotiation and the
referendum that we're gonna hold that
process is now properly underway the
fact that the attacks in the same day
take place in Europe and in the Arab
world paradoxically leads to the
opposite effects of those of that that
terrorists want instead of dividing us
show us very clearly that we have to be
united so the response will be more
unity Europeans must invest in their own
defence to deal with a dramatically
changed security environment we decided
that you found should be mobilised to
help strengthen europe's defence
industry including in research and
technology the european union foundation
principles where democracy solidarity
equality mutual respect the greek
government will continue decisively to
give the fight in favor of these
principles who continue to give the
fights on behalf of the european people
and of course on behalf of the great
people